when welcome to this video playing
lunatic ex why the sky is an insane
reading and Wow to 680 something ok I
always have cool cool games so they're
always interesting at least I mean I
have to say that my score is pretty bad
but I spoiled many good position so
let's see what happens we have a Italian
here with them industry and history and
see everybody plays the 93 lines
nowadays and this is not so easy for
black really not I looked at this
recently and it's not so clear how black
equalizes I mean not play at all ok so
I'm taking this there should be six
maybe mmmm it feels like some deja vu
here no but it looks ok let's do it what
is he after taking and playing this
position then let's go and let grand
master Peter michalek by the way do you
fear this is an insane rating firm
anyway let's see let's see what happens
ok I'm taking this and yeah it doesn't
look like much it really doesn't but
somehow i'm suffering in those positions
at least against good players so what to
do bring this to g6 so kind of standard
procedure and then play c65 even though
with a 5 in hmm maybe this isn't right
g3 not a move I understand to be honest
I don't understand the move it all okay
if I go d5 now is there something wrong
with that I don't see what what's wrong
so okay okay okay but let's say I take
and go to e6 then I play 97 next is
there a problem here when I don't see a
problem but this is the thing I usually
don't see a problem ever in the hint is
Italian positions and then I'm somewhat
worse and i'm suffering okay so if I go
with g6 here he cannot take right so he
has he has to go back the night has no
squares after taking ok and so 95 I can
take really not much going on can I
tickle them a little bit them will age
for you will probably preventer okay so
what's going on here I can unite end
games could be tricky with the space
advantage a knife coming to see five for
example would be pretty awful to me so
can I do something here if I go queen is
seven maybe 95 but I don't know that
doing something
I don't want to go see six and night see
phones when he doesn't get that the
moment but still I'm not totally sure
what to do here it's it's not it's not
like I'm usually worse but just I don't
have a clear idea what to do 95 I don't
know that really doesn't look like much
this one okay if I go see five and I am
I weakening myself there or I don't know
my knight on f6 is not good young this
is really not a good piece it just looks
at a 4g for which is all covered to d5
which is covered sup he's got he's got
the more active night interesting
let's take this piece if I would have
taken on before it opened up the
diagonal that that was certainly wrong
and now the night is on b6 it doesn't
look all that threatening them
mmm quite interesting I don't know what
to do early instead some what did some
wood worse you're sitting there the
night has to move somehow but if I move
f6 he gets 35 interesting he just goes
for the ending ok this is ending is
better for white a little bit at least
that's it for me and we can go to e6
isn't this ok now I mean of course them
I've screwed up the time but it wasn't
so easy to play and I mean it's not like
you it's completely equal or anything he
still is a bit better but I know I have
landing the rook in one move haha what
was that oh my god ah what an idiot ok
blah resign no I came what a band band
end to this game yeah I was kind of
happy with my defense at least it
doesn't feel like I'm in huge trouble
here he still has something with night
to see 5 and so on this is an
uncomfortable position and I don't
understand that is the thing probably c5
was wrong just probably this is a wrong
idea the engine wants to display this
move which is stronger it really is
stronger try to put this back end and
now I don't know y is still kind of kind
of slightly worse
I am not good at this position so I have
the same I mean it always looks like
nothing and it is probably not not much
but I don't I don't do it right I just
don't play in correctly Jim yeah the
computer finds improvements
unsurprisingly but it doesn't shoot it
shouldn't be that bad like this ok it's
g6 immediately is stronger yeah that's
true it's definitely true yeah I'm
helping him here I'm helping at me by
taking can you allow you to go back him
and ask him about those nights hmm
interesting this is helping him a little
bit at least I mean it's still not much
quite clearly but and there's one thing
that I did not see it all i can do i can
take and play this and this I certainly
didn't think about rookie 7 this is a
key idea if I get the rooks off I mean
this helps he still presses a little bit
he has this idea but it should be him it
should be enough yeah I didn't have a
very clear idea what to do here
the engine wants to toot wants to do
this the computer is just so strong
sometimes if with this i have this move
it makes an awful lot of sense here that
that idea and then this is certainly
okay for black with the two looks yeah
okay but yeah this is I mean you will
always find some improvements if you ask
the engine I'm just under some pressure
here yeah I felt the whistle but okay I
had a complete loser nation with rooks
eh I don't know I don't know okay it's
been a long day but still there this is
this is annoying I yes look here look
here and I don't really have anything
great against this really don't
absolutely cannot play this position
properly I have to really have to do
something about that it's I mean our I
thought I also totally dislike it you
just sit there and you're a girl you
cannot ever do anything you can just sit
around it is just extremely boring
general I should probably go for the two
nights or something this is a bit more
exciting yeah anyway guys thanks for
watching